all right experience plus retail apple
store probably three out of four people
who go there don't buy I don't know the
exact statistic to you know Disney Store
lots of games and videos being played
things to do there I went to the
Nespresso store in San Francisco I know
you've seen that one on Union Square but
it's a cafe and then in the basement you
can buy the pods and the machines are
everywhere and it's it's it's an
artistic endeavor Microsoft stores maybe
Google stores at some point what do you
think of this experience your retail
concept is this with us to stay you
mentioned JC Penney tried and failed
yeah because it's hard to change such a
large ship you know so it didn't work
for JC Penney that work for others yes
it's well I mean other necessity I think
it's the only thing that's going to
survive because the retail the only no
sybiz experiment I think when the
asbestos was probably even the best
example because we're cafe and just you
happen to buy the things there's a great
Canadian chain called Lululemon it's
just all over the place now and maybe
they're switching their locations to be
yoga studios because like it's so much
it's not about the product it's about
what's being represented and I think the
roughly knew this right so like no one
just has taken this to its logical
conclusion you know people want to
experience something then they go go to
these places because you can't just
optimize for single one interesting with
one thing but failure because it just
destroys per value for everyone so right
we need to be something special and I
think the Apple store like like every
retailer should like want to be more
like the episode the second the first
epic two of us out there it was clearly
that this was a bad idea
and again extremely innovative in that
way so I think this is what retail is
going so you you have to figure out what
is it that you've truly add to the
equation and and this is going to be a
lot like a hard question to ask
ourselves for for a lot of folks would
say what would you do if you were Best
Buy
I have no idea what to do with best by
giving the CEO of Shopify has no and you
have oh you've been studying e-commerce
for a decade you would have no idea how
to solve that problem you think they're
gonna die like Circuit City did I think
so I think they are going to die now
like I give people I give company
chances that are actively experimenting
mm-hm
and Best Buy is actively experimenting
like they like giving like handing over
a little part of a flow plate to Apple
for full ownership and now Microsoft
today was announced to so in a way maybe
like Best Buy segments out like a great
investors and starts parceling out these
two different brands that might be an
that might be a model that might work
but honestly I don't know I think it
experienced all these different brands
it's a Samsung corner a Microsoft corner
an apple corner but why would Apple want
to be in the same store as Microsoft and
Samsung right then we comes back to
distribution right like and and it
already has its own distribution so that
might not be very with Apple anymore and
they can control like if you if you if
you ever go to like an Apple corner in a
Best Buy
you know they control like it's a it's a
nicest table invent I Best Buy is really
one but the light above it is still best
buy light and therefore nothing looks as
nice as it does in the Apple store so it
doesn't quite work with a current
approach but maybe that's what kind of
things which can be potentially
optimized who do you think that
interesting stuff in that space have you
have you seen anybody who said wow
that's what it should be a little
dimension I think Lululemon is
absolutely on the right path and it's
sort of I use them as a like there's a
lot of people are following this but
then where you're getting the crazy
experiments box Park in London as I
think Oz what's that it's a mall in the
middle of London which is completely
made out of containers its vertex
shipping containers normal 40-footers
stack them in an interesting way and
then tell Puma to come and own one and
and turn it into whatever you know I
think that's cool and then those things
might actually not last very long I mean
there might be going away in a week or
so pop-up stores
pop-up stores or the logical conclusion
of pop-up stores I think might might be
great because you know if for a retailer
so I mean Shopify I think significantly
simplifies the process of getting your
business started and and
and be a successful van our customers
are successful so there's you know lots
of value and not having helping people
along so you have a great iPad case or
whatever and you want to build a
business surrounding that so you do that
you get noticed you use to applause up
you learn a bit about other kind of
things you need to do an internet like
adverts and these kind of things you
build with this online business but but
that's a silo right you do you you want
to do offline things but problem is
there's nothing between going like
having these products and then signing a
year lease you know that's how a
retailer in the works